[Music]
I personally was groomed and abused for
nearly a decade from the ages of five to
about 14 I then went through the the
justice system was sort of chewed up and
spat back out as many young girls are
people find it a lot easier to ignore
victims than they do to to go after the
perpetrators it was due to nervousness
about race that in many cases the police
and local authorities refused to take
these cases up they were worried about
being called racist they were worried
about being called right-wing or bigots
transaction exploitation is still
happening in towns and cities across the
UK this isn't a crime of the past and
this is another thing that that uh that
those impositions of authority like to
say that you know mistakes were made and
lessons were learned but this isn't
happening anymore well as recently as
2020 in England and Wales alone there
was hundreds over 700 reports of of
alleged child sexual exploitation by
refusing to let myself
become all consumed and become prey to
what was done to me I can I can defy all
of those expectations for me I can it's
kind of like giving the middle finger
and saying you tried everything you
could to break me and I still rose up
laughs
foreign
ometry I'm Francis Foster and
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today is a journalist and when I
introduce I should make clear she's not
Sam Smith she's Samantha Smith Samantha
Smith welcome to trigonometry thank you
for having me it's really good to have
you on the show we've got lots to talk
about before we do in fact help us set
it up by telling us your story who are
you how are you where you are what has
been your journey through life that
leads you to be sitting here talking to
us yeah of course I
um 20 years old I'm from I was
originally born in Surrey but I moved to
Telford in the West Midlands I was very
young I I sort of fell into this line of
work when I was 17 I had um I had always
been interested in politics and current
affairs but when I was 17 in the general
election 2019 I helped to run my local
MPS election campaign and from that I I
continue to to get involved in in local
politics when schools closed in 2020 I
was in March 20 I was 17 and I I come
from a disadvantaged background so I'm
legally estranged from my parent I was
homeless from the age of 16 legally I
was under Social Services you know sofa
saf from for about
16 months if I'm remembering rightly you
know moving from sleeping bags to sofas
every night sitting in McDonald's and
and nursing a cup of coffee until 6am am
to get the school bus in the morning but
I I I've always been on Twitter and I
wrote a tweet in August 2020 about the
cancellation of exams and the impact it
would have on disadvantaged students the
way that you know young people were
being judged based on their postcode
rather than their potential and that was
picked up by a spectator journalist who
asked if I'd be interested in writing a
piece for for the pay for the
publication and from there it sort of
snowballed and now here I am here I am
today well you've got an astonishing CV
for someone who's 20 years old so very
impressive and kudos to you and one of
the things you didn't mention is one of
the the big things that I think also
propelled uh your sort of role as a
commentator was your commentary on The
Grooming gangs and all of that because
it's something that you were personally
affected by as well yes so as I said I'm
I'm I grew up in Telford in the West
Midlands which is some of your your
viewers I'm sure will be aware is one of
the the key towns I suppose in the
National child sexual exploitation
Scandal over 1 000 girls fell victim to
organize grooming gangs in in Telford
over a course of of around 30 years I
personally was groomed and abused for
nearly a decade from the ages of five to
about 14 I
didn't come forward to to anyone with
the abuse I experienced until I was 16.
I then went through the the justice
system was sort of chewed up and spat
back out as many young girls are I
remember I'll never forget being told by
a social worker if you were physically
abused why were there no bruises that's
a that's a comment that really stuck
with me and
I think when for a long time I wasn't
aware that there were other girls in my
position there were other girls that had
been sexually abused that had been
groomed that had had
such a horrendous experience and so when
everything began began to come out in in
2018 2019 on The Grooming Scandal on the
uh the the culture of exploitation
ignorance and and silence in towns like
Telford it
struck home for me and I first spoke
about my story and my experience in 2020
that's when I went public with the types
of pose and I have worked my hardest to
bring awareness to the issue to amplify
survivors voices and to
just really keep the conversation in in
the the media attention because so many
girls like me have been disenfront
enfranchised and marginalized and
silenced by those in power so without
uh without people willing they're
willing to speak up whether it's
anonymously or or showing their faces I
wave my right to anonymity
perpetrators groomers rapists grooming
gangs they're going to be able to to
continue to thrive and continue to groom
rape abuse exploit other little girls
so that's that's why I I suppose I chose
to speak out yeah and we've had a
survival of the grooming gangs on the
show Dr Ella Hill I don't know if you're
familiar with her if you saw that
interview but she was anonymized and so
um you're very courageous to talk about
it in public the way that you do and I'm
curious because one of the things I've
discovered after we published that
interview I contacted every journalist I
could and I went look watch this
interview why don't you write something
about this and they're just they were
not interested
why do you think that is it's the
age-olds the age-old issue of cultural
Sensitivity I I would say people find it
a lot easier to ignore victims than they
do to to go after the perpetrators we
saw it with local councils with social
services with the police with the crown
prosecution service with mainstream
media with the government the list goes
on those in positions of power and
authority
don't want to to have this conversation
but because it exposes their own
failings it exposes the culture of
ignorance and silence and victim blaming
that was perpetrated over decades you
know young girls have been trying to
speak out this isn't something new this
isn't a a new occurrence of of all of a
sudden victims and survivors coming out
of the Woodworks and wanting to share
their stories no they went to sexual
health clinics they went to the police
they went to their teachers their social
workers and they were ignored at every
turn because they they were viewed as
second-class victims and those in in
positions of authority were scared about
the implications of accusing in the case
of grooming gangs particularly uh
predominantly Pakistani men of being
rapists and of raping predominantly
white working-class girls it's far
easier to Pivot the conversation away
from from victims and survivors because
they are traditionally disenfranchised
they don't come from the sort of
background that that has they don't have
support they don't have people that are
going to fight for them that are going
to stand up for them they aren't they
aren't privileged or affluent in in any
sort of way and
so that that only hope uh you know the
the legal system and and social services
and social care and if they don't listen
how how are the media going to be
expected to pick it up because
at the end it comes down to them being
treated as second-class victims I think
and they were treated as second class I
wouldn't even say second class I'd say
eighth class because some of the
language used about these girls was
disgusting I think the term white slags
was used as yes that was that was used
in Telford quite a lot and the uh the
Crowther report which was the the
independent inquiry into child sexual
exploitation in Telford it was revealed
that police and and local authorities
referred to the girls as shaggers
as white slags as child prostitutes that
was a big one the idea that a child can
prostitute themselves and these are
these are young girls girls as as young
as 10 or 11 in in the case of Telford
being told that this is your fault you
brought this on yourself you consented
it's because of your actions and your
lifestyle that you're in the position
you are today I again I remember being
told at one point that my actions had
led me to where I was and this was when
I was 16 or 17.
and it reinforces this idea this
internal into this internalized shame
that a lot of victims and survivors have
that somehow they brought it on
themselves when realistically and I'll
say this if I've said it once I've said
it a thousand times children cannot
consent to sex children cannot be asking
for it children cannot be pachy shaggers
or white or white slags or child
prostitutes children cannot consent and
those adults that are preying on
vulnerable little girls are criminals
they're rapists and they're Predators
they are they are the ones in the wrong
here not the little girls who were
abused and you're saying that and it
makes complete sense and of course it's
just a statement of fact but the the
reality is that's not how these girls
were perceived and it was a failing
right the way through that like you said
the court system do you think the police
are misogynist or misogynistic the
police forces that you from your own
experience from seeing the way they've
interacted with other victims
I'd say that it goes far deeper than
misogyny because misogyny is an inherent
hatred towards women but this isn't just
misogynistic it's classist it's I would
go so far to say it's racist to suggest
that that these young white
working-class girls are white slags for
being victimized and being abused it's
it's so much more than just a hatred of
women and girls it's a hatred of
everything that these that these little
these young children were it's attacking
every part of their identity and
suggesting that they are somehow
responsible for for the abuse they
suffered due to their immutable
characteristics so I say it you know and
and there's there's a wider debate about
the failings of the crown prosecution
service to bring uh sexual assault and
and sexual misconduct cases to trial I
believe it's I believe it's 96 and 98.6
percent of cases of rape cases never
make it to court in the UK that's just
one point 0.4 percent of victims that
are able to to have their their day in
court have their case even heard so how
many thousands one thousands of of
victims are are falling at the first
hurdle or the second hurdle or so on and
so forth
yes there is there is absolutely a
misogyny problem in the police I would
say you know the the fact that violence
against women and girls still isn't
being taken seriously in 2023 is beyond
beyond imagination but when it comes to
child sexual abuse and child sexual
exploitation this particular type of
crime goes far deeper than than plain
misogyny and there's also let's not
let's not ignore cowardice as well
because the fact that a large proportion
of the men committing these crimes came
from a Pakistani or Bangladeshi Muslim
background
suddenly that meant that they a lot of
police and especially a lot of political
commentators and a lot of politicians
started to get you know get cold feet
when dealing with this absolutely I and
this has been highlighted in the
independent reports in Rotherham
Rochdale Oldham Telford that those in
positions of power and I quote the
Telford report here failed to do their
most basic Duty in investigating reports
of of alleged child sexual exploitation
they there and it was also said in in
the quote in the quote the report and
Health Report that it was due to
nervousness about race that in many
cases the police and local authorities
refused to take these cases up I I'm a
firm believer in the fact that those in
in position of thought of authority were
blinded by fear when it comes to
grooming child sexual exploitation child
sexual abuse in general they were
worried about being called racist they
were worried about being called right
wing or or bigots or radicals they were
worried about the the consequences on
their own careers if they spoke up and
that's why there were so few Whistle
blowers and the few that did speak out
were absolutely slum they had their
careers ruined take Maggie Oliver who is
an absolutely brilliant woman Brave and
and awe-inspiring I work very closely
with her on a few on a few different
things and she was obviously the the
only
um police official to resign over the
the failings in in Greater Manchester
she was The Whistleblower in that in
that case and she for years had those in
positions of authority trying to destroy
her reputation and her credibility
trying to to suggest that she was a
crackpot or a fool or that she was
making this up or somehow
sensationalizing the scale of the abuse
when in we now know that she was
absolutely accurate in everything that
she was saying there were you know
Sexual Health Clinic workers social
workers teachers who raised concerns and
were discouraged from making reports due
to a belief and inherent belief that oh
this couldn't be going on in in towns
and cities like ours this this just
isn't true the girls are lying they're
making it up they're twisting the truth
it's
it's really astonishing how little
accountability we've seen for the
failings in across the the UK you know
how many police officers have lost their
jobs how many Council officials have
have faced any real consequences we saw
Dominic back recently was selected as a
labor candidate he's now stood down a
Zone Accord I'm assuming he jumped
before he was pushed although can you
just go into that because there's a lot
of people from overseas Samantha who
wouldn't know who this council is just
explain who he is and why he was pushed
well he could jump before he was pushed
so Dominic back was a Cabinet member in
Rotherham during the time of the child
sexual exploitation Scandal he and the
rest of the cabinet were forced to
resign in shame over their mishandling
of the of the of the Cry of the crisis
and this was in 2015 that his
resignation occurred I believe and what
was it 7 years later he was selected as
a labor parliamentary candidate for
Rother Valley the the slap in the face
that is to to victims and survivors to
suggest that a man who had to resign
literally in disgrace over his his
mishandling and his cabinet's
mishandling of the the child sexual
exploitation scandal in the area was
then allowed to to potentially run to
represent these same survivors in
Parliament he didn't represent them then
so how on Earth would he be fit for
public office now he eventually stood
down after GB news it was exposed this
this this this absolute Injustice and he
like I said the labor party didn't push
him out officially but he resigned on
his own of his own accord although I
believe that he you know there's no way
he wasn't facing internal pressure we've
seen in Telford again
um the the labor leader of telephone
Regan Council who is still the current
labor leader of the council
is running now to be the next MP for
Telford labor MP for Telford short
Council Sean Davis he's also the labor
government Association lead and so he
sits in the shower in the shadow cabinet
unofficially he wrote a letter in 2018
to the then Home Secretary calling for a
potential inquiry into a CSE and Telfer
to be shut down he said there was no
need for an inquiry and that the and the
scale of the abuse wasn't
um wasn't being actually accurately
reported that he believed that a
generalized inquiry into child sexual
abuse not child sexual exploitation and
National inquiry uh that had been
they've been in the works since the the
mid-2010s would be adequate in in
addressing the the transsexual
exploitation scandal in Telford that was
along with nine other very important men
that included the
um the suit the chief superintendent of
West Mercier police at the time the
cabinet member children and young
peoples Council Paul Watling he also
signed his name on that letter the uh he
he's now like I said running to be labor
MP for Telford and he he hasn't faced
any negative repercussions that even as
recently as as uh in 2022 he released a
statement saying he stated in a council
meeting that he was three years old at
the time that CSE was happening in
Telford that he continues to to shirk
responsibility for his council's
failings to to address child sexual
exploitation with you know shoddy
apologies and vague platitudes it seems
that those that were the architects of
the failings and in dealing with child
sexual exploitation are still allowed to
to continue their careers unscathed
despite the the thousands of lives that
they that they impacted negatively in
the thousands of girls that they ignored
for for years
hey Constantine do you like being
healthy of course in my country we judge
Men's Health by his ability to wrestle
bear turns out in London Russell bear
has very different meaning
we've already not just got out of hand
we will speak no more of this the secret
will be buried with my ancestors well if
you want to stay healthy and not feel
like you need to be buried with
Constantine's ancestors then you need to
try ag1 ag1 a simple and easy way to get
all new trends you need each serving
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Food Source
ingredients one scoop and you feel like
real men we use it on our America Tour
where we were constantly on the Move
living out of a bag and working every
day 81 meant we felt great look great
and we avoided getting sick one scoop a
day meant we knew we had all the
vitamins and minerals needed for the day
we had hugely successful trip it is very
economical and I felt strong enough to
wrestle American bird which we all know
is grotesly weak compared to Great
Russian if you're looking for a simpler
and cost effective supplement routine
1981 is giving you a free one-year
supply of vitamin D and five travel
packs with your first purchase go to
athleticgreens.com
trigonometry that athleticrins.com
trigonometry check it out and become
real men like me
Samantha and uh or I mean I this it's a
difficult conversation isn't it because
uh punishing people for things that
they've done is always gonna like we all
think it should happen but it's always
difficult to do because these you know
it's just it just is but I suppose from
your perspective would I be right in
thinking that your primary concern now
is making sure nothing like this ever
happens to anyone again right and so I
suppose the question for you is when we
first talked to Ella Hill which was I
think 2018 or 2019 it would have been it
was 2020 it was during the pandemic it
was just I think it was I think it was
before mate I think I think I think
let's say let's say let's call it 2019 I
mean I'm terrible with dates you're
probably right but let's say it was I
think since then in the last four years
this conversation thankfully is is being
increasingly had in public and people
are actually talking about it as you
said have been reports into it are you
confident that this is now something
that wouldn't be repeated or is it still
ongoing is it still not being properly
dealt with like what is your take what
is your sense of where where we are now
with this issue transaction exploitation
is still happening in towns and cities
across the UK this isn't a crime of the
past and this is another thing that that
uh that those impositions of authority
like to say that you know mistakes were
made and lessons were learned but this
isn't happening anymore well as recently
as 2020 I believe in in Telford alone
until the weekend uh sorry in in um in
England and Wales alone there was
hundreds over 700 reports of of alleged
child sexual exploitation of this kind
like grooming games
how has this happening I don't get it
like we've had all these reports they've
been brave people like you that have
come forward the police and the councils
and the social services and the
politicians some of them finally got the
balls to start talking about this how is
it possible that 700 people can still be
being abused in this way in once in one
town
I think it's progress is happening don't
get me wrong
conversation is a lot more open than it
was say 10 15 years ago but that doesn't
mean that adequate change has been made
in in Telford all use the Telford
example again uh there was a specialist
team in in Telford that was set up to to
deal with child sexual exploitation
cases and to to investigate this in
westmasia police but it was discovered
that as recently as 2020 2021 that team
had been scaled back to be virtually
non-existent the
I I think that those
those in power are saying all the right
things they're they're showing a
willingness quote-unquote to change and
to learn from the mistakes of the past
but whether that's actually being
implemented yet is another question
entirely and I also think that that
while the
the scale of abuse has now been exposed
and the
the the level of of the failings is is
being brought to national attention
there's still a long way to go in
dealing with this type of crime there's
still a lot of fear there's still a lot
of ignorant and arrogant around this
issue and so long as those in in power
continue to try and minimize the the
failings and and shirk responsibility
then little girls will continue to be
abused
some before we go any further we've used
the term child sexual abuse and child
sexual exploitation could you just
clarify the difference between those two
terms yes so child sexual exploitation
is uh in this set in this context is
referring to group based grooming it's
it's where a group of offenders of
perpetrators will Target a young victim
usually girls they will groom them
whether it's they're a different tactics
so there's the boyfriend tactic there's
wearing them with you know affection
with rides with gifts with with whatever
mean whatever means necessary to to
build a sense of trust with the victim
they then will exploit them sexually so
that's in in the case of of Telford many
of these girls were being abused by taxi
drivers by take away owners uh and they
were being brought to sex parties or
passed around between men
often prostituted for money but it's
group based sexual exploitation and in
grooming child sexual abuse is it refers
to the broad umbrella of of abuse again
of sexual abuse of children so that can
include abuse within the family it does
include child sexual exploitation so
child's sexual exploitation is a form of
child sexual abuse but it falls under
the umbrella and child sexual abuse is
you know the broader definition uh
grooming can also fall in either
category it can grooming can be online
it can be in person it can be via VIA
social media whatever means grooming
takes place and child sexual
exploitation again is grooming forms a
part of that
um and I've I've always clarified so I
was I was a victim of child sexual abuse
and grooming in in Telford I was abused
and and
um
and room for nearly a decade by
successive men I myself wasn't a victim
of the the particular type of of child
sexual exploitation that many of that
many fellow survivors were but my
experience
of the failings of the police and local
authorities and those impositions of
power to address exploitation and
grooming and and to to bring Justice in
my case was identical to to uh to many
of my fellow survivors and so that's I
suppose that's why and my experience of
the failings in Telford to to
to give little girls Justice and protect
little girls from abuse was what
inspired me to to come forward I suppose
yeah and Samantha uh one of the things I
find so incredible about everything
you've been able to do with your life is
you've overcome these awful experiences
and it's something I we always think
about it's like everyone experiences
some form of you know adversity and
Trauma and whatever in your case
obviously at a much worse and extensive
level and yeah here you are
you're 20 years old you've run an MPS
campaign at the age of 17 you're on TV
you're writing columns how have you been
able to overcome all this how have you
been able to deal with the challenges
that you faced don't get me wrong I
wasn't
I wasn't like I am now when I was you
know 16 17 years old I I wasn't done
I am
you see I I I had a lot of anger I I had
a lot of fear a lot of resentments a lot
of Shame and I when I was younger when I
first came forward about the abuse that
I suffered I was a scared little girl
who was terrified of speaking out
because I felt like I had somehow
brought on myself like I was responsible
for the abuse I and much of this this
rhetoric was instilled in Me by those in
in positions of authority
I it took me a long time to overcome a
lot of that anger and that guilt and
that shame and I still I still struggle
with those feelings on a daily basis but
the way that I I suppose I was able to
come out the other side and now speak
about my my story as I do is
I I it sounds very strange I
compartmentalize it in the way of what I
experienced was awful it was it will it
will stay with me for the rest of my
life but if by speaking out about it and
by using my pain and my trauma and and
airing it out and and exposing these
injustices if I can use my experience to
enforce change and to help even just one
little girl see that
you can get through it and that you can
survive you can become stronger you can
be successful then it will make it all
worth it you know everything that I
have done since speaking out about about
my experiences is
in spite of what was done to me I think
that the the best kind of Revenge is
success and
by not allowing my experience to Define
me not by not allowing and I hate that I
hate the tan victim I don't like to
think of myself as a victim even though
I was victimized
I think that
by
refusing to let myself
become all consumed and become prey to
what was done to me I can
I can defy all of those expectations for
me I can it's kind of like giving the
middle finger and saying you tried
everything you could to break me and I
still rose up again
it's very impressive did you ever did
you ever get any justice for what
happened to you was anyone ever
convicted no no no and were you offered
any kind of therapy or anything of that
kind yes it's uh it's a very very
complicated system I would say the
justice system in the UK in England and
Wales specifically so when I first went
to the police about what I experienced I
was assigned an Israel which is an
independent sexual violence advisor and
I was referred for sexual abuse therapy
through an independent charity that
worked with the police I was also
because I was 16 I was shipped to a
child psychologist and a child
psychiatrist to see if there was
anything underlying uh in in my own
psychological makeup I suppose that
would and it was phrased to me as so
that they knew how to support me best
but I I came to to realize that it was
partly an interrogation and a means of
finding out if there was anything
underlying mentally that would make it
more difficult for me to be believed in
court and we've seen this in in rather
and Rochdale Telford of victims and
survivors who had underlying mental
health difficulties or who had
behavioral difficulties or whatever it
was vulnerabilities that they were told
that there they wouldn't be a suitable
suitable witnessing court and that it
wasn't a good idea to proceed with the
case because they don't know how they
would play in front of a jury
so I I had all of these different
services around me and my own thinking
it doesn't sound like they were
massively helpful at this point
my independent sexual violence advised
my is for I will say was absolutely
brilliant she was it genuinely felt as
though she was on my side but another
and this is something about the this is
something internal about the justice
system that people might not know when
it comes to sexual abuse therapy one of
the big things when you're when you have
a case that's ongoing is any therapy
that you receive you're not actually
allowed to talk about what happened to
you in specific details so you can't
talk about the abuse you can't talk
about any particulars you can't name any
names you can't
really you can't address the actual
abuse itself
at all because if you do then the and it
did come to court then your private
notes your your therapy sessions could
be
um called upon as evidence in in court
and so basically your prior your medical
privacy would be compromised if you
discussed the particulars of your case
during therapy while the case was
ongoing and as as many many survivors
will know it's a very long process to
get to court I mean mine was my case was
dropped to no further action because the
CPA the CPS believes that there wasn't a
realistic Prospect of conviction due to
it being a historic case
I it the process took in nearly two
years for me to not even reach court so
that was two years where I was receiving
some sort of support but I wasn't
actually able to address any any of the
trauma and the abuse that I experienced
it was sort of the way that it was
described was keeping the keeping you
ticking along until you can actually
access the full package of therapy which
was so there were two types of therapy
there was the pre-trial therapy and then
there was the the the post police
involvement therapy which was the full
monty where you could discuss everything
and really get the help that that many
victims and survivors need as as I
needed so for two years I was in this
sort of purgatory where I was receiving
support to essentially stop myself from
spiraling into into a depressive episode
or having a full-on mental breakdown
during this very tumultuous period of
police investing Asians and evidence
Gathering and you know going back and
forth to the CPS and my and my uh the
police sergeant that was in charge of my
case
but I I wasn't able to to Really address
any of the the Deep Roost issues and so
that's something that many people don't
know you know while while this very long
laborious Court
proceeding is taking place victims and
fives aren't actually able to get the
support they need and the way they need
it in many cases Sam listening to your
story the one thing that I mean there
are many things that I find very
upsetting uh someone who used to teach
and used to teach vulnerable kids
because I used to teach in very very
deprived areas I know for a fact that
gangs that these types of individuals
they target the vulnerable they target
the the girls or the boys who don't come
from stable family backgrounds the ones
who struggle at school the ones who are
for whatever reason vulnerable or
labeled as difficult and the fact that
these victims won't get their day in
court
because they won't an inverted commas
play well in front of a jury I find
utterly disgusting absolutely I I and
this is this is what I this is the point
that I was getting to earlier where
victims and survivors have every
possible immutable characteristic
exploited and and turned against them
when they try and seek Justice for the
abuse they suffered many as you said
many victims of this particular type of
crime and it isn't just criminal sexual
exploitation it's criminal exploitation
of children as well come from
disadvantaged backgrounds whether they
you know in in the case of child sexual
exploitation many of the victims in
Telford not all of them because any
child can be abused any child can be
exploited anyone can fall victim to this
sort of this sort of crime and I don't
want to denigrate the experiences of any
survivors but many survivors were
already known to Social Services they
were already in care they had difficult
family backgrounds with their parents
were you know alcoholics or drugs or
absent or whatever it is many of the
many of the survivors and victims in in
cases like in towns and cities like
Telford
were from a disadvantaged or vulnerable
background and so it begs the question
with all of these services that are
supposed to be around supporting
children supporting these kinds of
children how did everyone seem to to
fail to see the signs or fail to take
action to protect them
in in the case of Social Services there
was as I said in in Telford for example
a massive failing failure to to not
notice the size but to act on them
because it was you know there were
children that were going to sexual
health clinics for the morning after
pill every single week there were
children as long as 13 or 14 that were
having abortions who told the the work
their social workers oh I've got a
boyfriend who's 27 or whatever oh this
is happening this is happening to me
this is what I was doing this is where I
was and yet no no further action was
taken I think that
it it really speaks to you and and the
the point that I was making another as
well about the justice system being more
than misogynistic
it isn't just that many of these victims
were little girls it's that they were
from backgrounds that were less than
ideal they didn't fit the cookie cutter
profile of the perfect victim they
weren't going to be able to and this is
something that I always get I get a lot
of people on Twitter that especially
that say it's always Twitter isn't says
the armchair experts themselves that say
oh you don't sound like someone that
would have been a victim of of grooming
or sexual abuse oh you don't look like
someone that would have that would have
been a victim
and it just creates this Paradox where
any any child who isn't the the perfect
victim who doesn't speak well come from
an affluent family play well in front of
a jury who doesn't tick the boxes of
what the the crown prosecution service
is looking for in in someone that will
play well in court
it suggests that they are somehow less
deserving of justice and less deserving
of support and if if they if in my as in
my case you do have have a a posh accent
they've been told
um or you you went to to a good school
you don't fit the typical victim profile
on the other side of things people
somehow believe that oh you couldn't
possibly have experienced this this
isn't you know are you sure that this
happened there's it's damned if you do
damned if you don't damned if you're
disadvantaged and damned if you're not
um but in the case of child sexual
exploitation in particular you're right
that the that the majority of these
girls were white working class disadvant
advantaged from from vulnerable
backgrounds and predators that those
that that took advantage of them preyed
on their vulnerability and were able to
exploit them groom them abuse them rape
them
because there was no one around them
that was willing to to protect them
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
so and Samantha coming back to you
mentioned the the after the the case and
the investigation and the case doesn't
go to court you get this full monty
therapy was that useful was did that
help you on in your recovery from
everything
I think it was uh a mixture I'll be 100
honest and say that so I
by the time my case was dropped I had
just aged out of the system so I was no
longer able to access so my social
worker closed me closed my case I was
shoved off and told you're an adult now
go away leave us alone
um just simply like that pretty much
there's there's no there's no there was
no continuation of support for me um
from child services and during the
obviously during the pandemic this was
exacerbated in the fact that you know
you weren't able to really see see your
workers face to face and so on I
received a certain amount of support
um and and therapeutic intervention a
little bit of the four Monty but I I'll
be fully honest and say that at the time
that I was
receiving this this therapy I wasn't
ready to engage I wasn't at the point
where I was ready and after I think part
of it was was because I spent two years
in this limbo of of living through this
experience every day but not being able
to talk about not about it not being
able to address it and so by the time
that I was able to to access this full
service I suppose of therapy I was
scared I was angry I I was angry that my
case has been dropped I was afraid I
still felt this massive shame and an
inability to process it
and I yeah I assumed I wasn't ready to
to go through it I'm now in a far better
place and I have to see what I'm kind of
get trying to get at Samantha what I'm
trying to get out of you is how come
you're so well put together
because like you've obviously moved on
yeah and you've moved past it and you're
now living your life and you're very
accomplished and very successful and
you've got a bright future and you're at
University studying law and everything's
brilliant right and and the thing that's
cute well not everything
I was just gonna say I know it's not
very
it's not very trendy to say but
medication medication really helped me
I'm on and this is getting a little bit
vulnerable I suppose
but I I'm on antidepressants I'm on
anti-anxiety medication I'm on sleeping
tablets I take sleeping tablets most
nights to to keep myself going I have
brilliant wonderful support systems now
that I didn't have when I was younger
you know my and I'll always say I'm
although everything that happened to me
was was awful and horrible I was very
very lucky to go to a wonderful school I
went to a to a little grammar school in
in the middle of the Shropshire
Countryside that took two that took over
two hours to get to in the morning so
don't get me wrong it wasn't all
sunshine and rainbows but I you know
when I was homeless when I was sofa
surfing my head of year who I will
always regard as someone that saved my
life and someone I'm she's my she's my
phone background actually she's on my
lock screen a photo of me and her she
did my laundry for me she let me keep my
bags keep my clothes in her office when
I when I didn't when I didn't you know I
wasn't able to carry them around with me
every night she made sure that I could
shower at school and I didn't have
access to a shower she ensured that I
had at least one hot meal a day every
day bought me toiletries and a towel and
things like that
now at the stage that I'm at in in my
life at the moment my mp my local MP the
MP for Telford Lucy Allen she helped me
like absolutely no one else and I you
always hear that age-old stereotype of
Tories don't care about anyone but
themselves and I would say that she in
my opinion defies that stereotype she
took a chance on the 17 year old with no
experience and and a very difficult
background gave me a shot during the
2019 campaign she took me under her Wing
I ended up working for her for for
nearly two years before I went to
University she is one of the my biggest
supporters and an absolutely amazing
Mentor that I'm privileged to have there
are other other amazing people that I
have in my life who I can go to for
advice for support for a shoulder to cry
on or someone to lean on when I'm having
a tough day because not every day is
like this I spend there are days that I
and again getting a bit vulnerable but
there are days that I spend just color
up in bed watching Netflix and not able
to do anything because it's it's and
this is something about the process that
isn't off that isn't always talked about
you know you see polished products on on
TV with hair done and and makeup on and
a nice jumper I'm very sorry we're
wearing more makeup than her what are
you talking about
once you get into your 40s yeah yeah
this is the best it's going to be yeah
this is It's a journey I would say and
I'm not I'm by no means perfect I'm by
no means healed but yeah I'd say that's
how I get through it on a day-to-day
basis I've got amazing support systems
now that I that I'm very grateful to
have and I didn't have when I was
younger I
um very well medicated and and I just
take every day as as it comes and how
how have your experiences shaped how you
think about
you know you mentioned working for a
conservative MP how have your experience
has shaped how you think about the world
because you mentioned not wanting to be
a victim and of all the people in the
world who could be a victim if they
wanted to and who could cash in on it
and capitalize on it someone in your
position is like perfectly placed to do
that and it's the trendy thing nowadays
to be a victim and you get people who
you know had two parents went to a nice
school went to a good University and
because of the color of their skin or
because they're a woman because of this
they're on TV talking about how
oppressed they are and here you are
saying I don't want to be a victim it's
the Monopoly of victimhood isn't it I
think as
as cliche as it sounds I've learned to
realize what the big things are what the
big issues are and I I've I guess that's
part of that's partly because of what I
experienced but I've come to realize
that bad hair day is in the end of the
world and you know the this idea that
everyone has to be a victim that that
your your horrible experiences or your
your inherent your inherent immutable
characteristics somehow make you you
more or less deserving of of special
treatment or or support or the the
victimhood badge I I just don't buy into
any of it and that's part of the reason
why I'm a conservative I always I always
get asked why why are you conservative
surely you'd be a labor supporter sure
surely you'd be left wing if you have
gone through all of this you know you
were a victim of the system how are you
not left-wing how do you not want to
change it and and I always respond in
that I do want to change it but I don't
think that you can
enforce change and impact change by by
perpetuating that victimhood I think
that the there's something deeply
anti-aspirational about this whole
identity politics critical race Theory
uh you know identitarian victimhood uh
the victim Purge I don't know
story yeah culture sorry I am no no I
yeah I just think that there's something
so deeply anti-aspirational about it the
idea that if you have gone through a
terrible time or you were born with a
different color skin that you are always
going to be behind and that nothing is
ever going to go your way that you need
to have special treatment you need to
have the the white man step aside for
you to be successful it suggests that
that people aren't capable of succeeding
off their own Merit and I think that
with the right support and don't get me
wrong especially for for
for those that have experienced child
sexual exploitation or grooming or
transsexual abuse it is very very hard
it's
it isn't easy to to pick yourself up and
to to get out of that but with the right
sort of support
anyone is capable of achieving and I
think that the conservative messaging
and more show is far more akin to
aspiration and and hand-ups not handouts
than than the left-wing rhetoric I think
that there's just there's nothing that I
see that is
that is fruitful or Progressive or
positive about telling people that
you're a victim you should feel angry at
the world you should hate everyone
around you for for making life so tough
for you no it should be the the
messaging should be yes life can be life
can be bad life can be really really
really sucky but
you you are capable of achieving you're
capable of doing something better you're
capable of lifting yourself out of that
situation and these are the things that
we want to do to support you with that
uh this is a question that I didn't
think I was going to ask but you're such
a remarkable person that I'm I'm going
to ask it what do you think about the
way that we talk about
exploitation rape abuse in the media now
and particularly with things like me too
etc etc do you think we discuss it in an
honest way do you disagree with the way
that we discuss it
I think that
the one thing I would say is while again
the conversation is more open than it
used to be people still aren't being
candid about the nature of this type of
crime what are we not saying I I mean as
as in my own experience I've been asked
going on shows before can you not
mention the word rape or can you not
mention the the word Pakistan
they're asking you not to say the word
rape or not to mention the race because
because somehow it is too too much for
the modernists it's unpalatable to talk
about it in such in such a Frank detail
and I think that that's what I would
would say needs to be improved upon
because realistically if the police can
say if the police were allowed to say
that white working class girls victims
of transsexual exploitation were white
slags and pachy shaggers why can I not
repeat it on national TV and expose
exactly what it is that they said why is
there this double standard in the media
and in in television and radio that
somehow the girl the girls that were
that were abused raped exploited groomed
by predominantly Pakistani Muslim men
were were forced to go through this but
we're but we as a society can't can't
bear repeating it in in open and honest
detail I think that the conversation is
far from from Frank and open and honest
and that there needs to be a lot more
done to unwrap the cotton wool around
the mainstream media and say that as
long as as long as we have these these
sensitivities and these no-go areas
around the topic of rape and
exploitation then little girls are going
to continue to be abused because it just
furthers this this culture of ignorant
and victim blaming and silence and shame
it it only silence only serves to to
protect the perpetrators of this crime
and cultural sensitivity political
correctness only serves to protect the
Predators
Samantha do you think one of the reasons
why with the metoo movement Harvey
Weinstein was such a huge figure is that
and push back if you disagree on this is
because he very neatly encapsulated what
we want a villain to be you know he's a
rich white guy who's powerful you know
and people felt that they couldn't you
know they they they couldn't challenge
him and he obviously acted it was just
him and then everybody else kind of
obeyed him and did and also his victims
are very high status women usually right
yeah that helps yeah I did a a piece for
the mail on this issue exactly the
Harvey Weinstein and and
um the Harvey Weinstein issue and the
Jeffrey Epstein and Glenn Maxwell case
uh the the reason why these celebrity
cases the same with prince Andrew were
such a a national Scandal why the the
papers were doing double page spreads on
Elaine Maxwell's Court outfit and
covering it wall to war for weeks and
weeks was because it appeals it appeals
to our societal
our societal Intrigue and interest with
the with the idea of celebrity these
were this was a lifestyle that the
ordinary person couldn't even dream of
you know private jets and and Epstein
Island and celebrities and millions of
dollars being traded for sexual for
sexual favors it was very much
glamorized and mystified and played into
the into the myth of Hollywood I would
say and and it was far more glamorous to
talk about billionaire as on on private
boats and and Islands then you know a
working class white girl from Telford
being being raped around the back of of
a of a kebab shop it's
in my opinion it was so it was so highly
covered because the victims and the
perpetrators and to some extent the
victims were celebrities they were part
of this jet setting lifestyle that many
of us can only dream of whereas once
again it isn't it isn't glamorous or
cool or fashionable to talk about little
girls in rather than Rochdale Oldham
Banbury Telford Etc being groomed and
exploited by predominantly Pakistani men
and do you think that was one element or
there's there's lots of elements of the
of the whole me too movement that
ignored these types of crimes
think that
the Mewtwo movement is a is a difficult
one because that it was very much it
existed in a time and place in in
Hollywood
specifically I would say it was the idea
that it was it was demystifying the the
Hollywood myth and showing that sexual
abuse and exploitation and and
harassment was very much alive and well
in Hollywood and show it and lifting the
lid on this culture of misogyny and and
grooming and and victim blaming within
Hollywood I think that child's sexual
exploitation abuse is completely removed
from that it's an entirely different
castle of fish because and and this
isn't me saying that that it shouldn't
be that people shouldn't raise the sort
of awareness of child sexual
exploitation they did at the metoo
movement but I think that again it it's
it all comes down to the class of the
victims and the perpetrators
the metoo movement was
a specifically focused on this celebrity
the celebrity lifestyle and it did
snowboard some to some extent and there
were ordinary women quoting quotes that
were speaking out about the abuse they
experienced but it was very much to do
with Hollywood and and the celebrity
world and the the sexual harassment that
was going on there whereas watch is
happening in towns like Telford rather
than Rochelle Etc is a lot closer to
home it's a grooming crisis in our own
backyards and that is very very
different from the metoo movement uh
Samantha there's one other question that
I wanted to ask you because of all the
people that we've interviewed pretty
much other than Ella you have more
reason than anyone I think to hate men
and we do live in a society where
increasingly that narrative from certain
Quarters at least seems to me like it is
being Advanced and it is being pushed
and you know toxic masculinity this and
men are that and the patriarchy and this
and that and like I say I mean if you if
you were to sit in that chair and go you
know what I think men are trash I'd be
like you know what I generally don't
agree but I think you've got a reason to
you've got to pass you you've got you
can say that what do you make of the way
we have the conversations around these
issues men and women men's roles women's
roles and Society Etc
I think
there's very big difference between
hating men and wanting to to change the
culture around masculinity and and the
way that women are treated in society I
don't hate men I think that many men are
are perfectly decent and upstanding
human beings I'm not I'm definitely not
putting on my tinfoil hat and raising my
Pitchfork and my steak and and calling
for all of them to be banned in in the
Town Square but I think that the the way
that the conversation needs to be had
and this is the problem with with some
radical feminist movements I would call
myself a feminist but I wouldn't say
that I'm a new wave or a current
feminist in the way that it it seems to
have to have spiraled now where you know
people people say the future is female
and and uh Apple Man and that that we
should eat eat all men that are all men
are awful horrible nasty criminals and
that they should they should all be you
know just expelled from society crazy
um the conversation really needs to be
around
how can we
deconstruct these ideas of toxic
masculinity and and misogyny in society
because misogyny is still a very very
big problem especially in the major
institutions of this of this country and
in across the world the police the the
government the way that women are
treated in in
in all areas of society still needs to
be improved and it would be remiss to
obviously women can be perpetrators of
sexual abuse as well that's that that
does happen but in the majority of cases
men are the perpetrators and women are
the victims or little girls or little
boys are the victims women and children
so it's it's about having an honest and
open conversation but also not
villainizing everybody there's I think
that we we seem to have lost Nuance in
modern political debate there's no
ability for people to say that this and
it's the same with with Pakistani Muslim
grooming gangs that you aren't able to
say that not all Pakistani people are
bad not all Muslims are bad but there is
a significant problem within this
community that is that is unique for the
most part to this community this is
going on and we need to figure out how
we can address it it's the same with men
people say oh it's not all men that do
this you know women can be rapists too
blah blah blah blah yes that's true I'm
not name that I don't think that anyone
is denying that that it's not all men
that are that are perpetrators of sexual
abuse but there are too many women that
are victims there was a there was a I
think it was an nspc C uh study that
came out that found that I think it's
like 96 of of of girls had experienced
some sort of sexual harassment before
the age of 16. that's a staggering
figure so yes it isn't all men but it's
too many women yes in my opinion and so
we can we can have this conversation and
say that there is a problem with with a
lot of men abusing women and children
but that doesn't mean that it's all
meant that are bad and evil and horrible
and and this is where maybe I would add
even a little bit more news the fact
that there are a lot of female victims
does not mean that there are a lot of
male perpetrators necessarily right it
could be that a small minority of people
commit a lot of those offenses or do a
lot of those things over time and I
think that's maybe where part of the
Nuance is getting lost because I
actually happen to think and you know
this is just my opinion that one of the
solutions to some of these problems is
for men who are not like that to have
more overall in protecting them
absolutely right and I think that's
where my concern is sometimes when we
start to Tar people with the same brush
you're actually pushing good men away
from being involved and being active in
looking after people because that is you
know it's not a fashionable thing to say
but that is part of men's jobs is to
protect others you know protect children
protect women protect Partners Etc and I
think we're losing that a little bit as
well I think that that you're absolutely
right in in the fact that men can do a
lot more to help protect women and
children I think that it's it's the the
discussion that's had the topic of of
what can we be doing to raise our sons
and our and our young men to be better
when they than previous generations that
came before them you know it starts at a
very young age these these toxicity this
toxic ideology and this idea that women
are somehow beneath men or that they are
only to be to be used for sexual
gratification or pleasure that that
somehow women are inferior needs to be
tackled and addressed in the same way
when it comes to racism it needs to you
know people aren't born racist people
aren't born sexual predators this
behavior is learned there was a case in
in Telford it's on an ongoing case so I
won't comment on it too much but there
was an on there's an ongoing case in
Telford of a boy a 13 year old boy who
has been arrested for I believe it's
nine counts of rape and and and several
other sexual assaults of women aged of
women and girls age 16 to 34. this is a
13 year old boy that has been accused of
these crimes he wasn't born on that way
this behavior is learned whether you
learned it from from his father or his
schoolmates or his uncle or his brothers
or whoever it is someone taught this
little boy that it was okay to sexually
assault women and so tackling that at
the at a very young age and dispelling
this this this sort of ideology and
teaching young boys how to be good men
how to be a good upstanding law-abiding
respectful citizens is the key I think
to to to making a difference but let's
let's not get get it twisted people will
always there will always be bad people
in the world people will always rape
abuse exploit people will always be be
horrible but
I think that so long as we continue to
put up these barriers to open an honest
conversation and part and one of those
barriers is this this lack of nuance and
the the rhetoric that all men are bad
and that all men should be it should be
exiled and whatever well like I said
you'd be yeah
you'd be forgiven for saying that if you
wanted to but I guess my point would be
with that 13 year old boy you actually
think you I think you put your finger on
it which is if that boy had a father in
the home who taught him how to treat
women properly that never would have
happened right and and I think that's
part of the answer as well is is for men
to be better
um I think that's really important
Samantha anyway it's been a real
pleasure speaking with you although
obviously it's a difficult conversation
uh but an important one and and we're
I'm really glad we've been able to have
you on uh to keep reminding people that
these things aren't over uh it's still
going on there's still work to do and uh
we thank you for for sharing your story
with us and for coming on you've got a
bright future ahead of you so we wish
you all the best test before we let you
go we've got our final question and some
questions from our supporters that
they've already submitted a final
question as always is what's the one
thing we're not talking about as a
society that you think we really should
be
I'm going to go a little bit left field
here and because we've we've obviously
talked a lot about child sex
exploitation grooming and I would say
that would be the obvious answer for
what we need to be talking about more in
society so I'm gonna I'm Gonna Keep It
light here and say Opera Opera is the
thing that we need to be talking about
more and I I don't think my Twitter
follows I tweeted about it earlier and I
don't think that it was it was a bit too
Niche for them but I believe that Opera
is the best genre of music out there I
believe that it is that it should be
mainstream that everyone should be
taking their children to see La Traviata
or Carmen or cosifantuti I think the
Opera needs to be it needs to be spoken
about and revered more than it is in
society
smoking like a real conservative can I
say you know my grandfather here's a
story my grandfather was a working class
Joiner for up in Wigan in the north of
England and he volunteered to join the
Army during the second world war and he
went and part of what he thought was in
Italy and he fell in love with Opera he
fell in love with Opera he fell in love
with Italy so he came back and he was
working in
on the on the in the railways with all
these big other working-class men and
they all thought he was a bit odd
because he would be there working whilst
listening to La traviarta I love that I
think that you know Opera is and this is
gonna this is turning into a
conversation about accessibility in
Opera but Opera is is far more
accessible than it used to be and
there's there's a there's a joy to be
found in appreciating a good musical
score forget what forget lizzo and and
Sam Smith and Harry Styles and and all
of this modern filth that's getting put
out
I think I always like to think of myself
as an 85 year old woman trapped in I've
got her opinions
a young person's body you know all I
want is to sit at home with a glass of
wine I do this sometimes sit at home
with a glass of wine and and a you know
a Camembert and listen to Coffee fan 2D
or LA bohem on on the radio it's it's
it's something I think we need to get
reject modernity and an Embrace
tradition that's my message for for all
of your lovely followers we're gonna
call this episode ban This Modern filter
Samantha where can people find you
online if they want to follow your work
and and follow along with your career
I'm on Twitter at Samantha tag Hoy
that's
t-a-g-h-o-y spelled as it sounds I'm not
really active on anything else I think
that Twitter is my is my my poison of
choice but if people are interested in
reading my my print journalism I'm a
columnist for The Spectator and the
daily mail if you search Samantha Smith
spectator or Samantha Smith daily mail
you you might find a 1970s peace
activist first but I'll I'll be the
second one that shows up so yeah that's
that's the way that people can find me
thank you so much for coming on it's
been a real pleasure to meet you and
thank you for watching and listening
we'll see you on locals for the bonus
questions take care and see you soon
if I could ask the government to enact
one policy
right right now it would be to
[Music]